das hemmt schweißgetränkt altherr tan
durch champions straßen
er hat keine zeit zum reden er muss
jetzt schnell sein es geht um sein
zuhause
ich suche ein auto ich muss umziehen
warum die häuser hier werden abgerissen
ich brauche eine neue wohnung mit dem
hab und gut der familie wartet seine
tochter an der hauptstraße es soll
gleich regnen
da zählt führt an jede minute damit das
wenige was man besitzt nicht nass wird
wieviel 120 yuan 15 euro meine sachen
stehen schon da oben gerade mal vor zwei
monaten haben sie ihm gesagt dass sie
das ganze viertel abreißen um platz für
luxuswohnungen zu machen dann ist
handwerker und wird wohl einige davon
bauen aber er kann sie sich nicht
leisten
deswegen muss er geht die neue wohnung
ist weiter weg und doppelt so teuer es
wird schwer sein seine familie
durchzubringen
wenn du nicht umzieht stellte die stadt
den strom und das wasser ab dann wohnt
in einem stadtteil von change 150.000
menschen leben hier meistens arbeiter
und einfache angestellte wenig geld und
kleine träume die gassen sind eng und
die wohnungen sind bezahlbar das viertel
liegt mitten in der stadt nicht weit
entfernt von den hochglanz fassaden
beste ballade
die stadtoberen wollen noch mehr
luxuriöse wolkenkratzer auf der anderen
seite der bucht liegt die andere
megacity hongkong die stadt die pekings
machthabern so viel ärger macht angeles
soll wachsen um sie in schach zu halten
die offiziellen stadtentwickler wie dr
schau wissen dass sie planen die neuen
luxus meint chinas eliten anzulocken ein
milliardengeschäft
das datei bei sisu league mit einem high
tech park tendenz damit dieser sich
weiterentwickeln kann brauchen wir gut
ausgebildete leute die wiederum bessere
lebensumstände wollen für die kleinen
geschäfte heißt dies dass aus chinas
großes ziel von der
weltmarktführerschaft nimmt keine
rücksicht auf die zukunft der kleinen
leute
wer nicht mithalten kann verliert seine
existenz und muskel schenken will nur
die menschen die für die
hightech-industrie nützlich sind die
leute die sich nicht mit technik
auskennen werden verscheucht schön schön
war vor 40 jahren noch ein kleines
fischerdorf mit 30.000 einwohnern nun
symbolisiert die 15 millionen metropole
chinas rasanten aufstieg das silicon
valley asiens nennen sie schenken weil
hier die chinesischen technik giganten
ihre zentrale haben
für herrn jan ist da wohl kein platz
mehr wir treffen ihn in einer
seitenstraße seiner mietwohnung
es ist nicht ungefährlich für ihn über
seine wut mit uns zu reden
der vater zweier kinder hat ein kleines
baugeschäft eine bescheidene karriere
er hat gegen den abriss seines viertels
offiziell protestiert sie sperrten ihn
ein
die polizei hat mich angerufen ich soll
vorbeikommen ich habe gefragt warum sie
haben gesagt sie wollen mit mir reden
als ich dort ankam nahmen sie mir mein
handy weg damit war ich nicht
einverstanden ich konnte mich aber nicht
wehren
sie legten mir sogar handschellen an das
20 stunden hielten sie mich fest
detaillierte informationen darf ich
nicht weitergeben menschen muss immer
größer werden ohne rücksicht es führt
ein duell mit hongkong die beiden
vorzeige städte chinas die sich beim
wachsen zuschauen können im sportzentrum
in tschechien ist verborgen das
chinesische militär stationiert aber im
stadion selbst trainieren die soldaten
der volksarmee nicht mehr anders als
noch vor wenigen wochen
peking weiß dass es hongkong als
finanzzentrum braucht wohl noch viele
jahre
hongkong genießt das vertrauen der
internationalen firmen
chen chen ist technologiezentrum
hongkong ist das tor nach draußen
chen chen ist wichtig für das inland
kurz vor acht uhr morgens machen sich
ein shams bürger auf den weg nach rom
kommt an manchen tagen bis zu 670.000
eine halbe stunde später werden sie dort
sein wo laut chinesischer
staatspropaganda chaos und terror
herrschen
keiner will so richtig über die lage in
hongkong reden schon gar nicht mit
ausländischen medien denen sie
misstrauen aber viele eltern schicken
ihre kinder nach hongkong weil dort die
schulen
die bildung finde ich gut in hongkong
ist die besser als in tschechien ja
außerdem gehen wir in den nordteil zur
schule dort ist es sowieso mehr
chinesisch geprägt machen sie sich
sorgen
nein ich finde es gibt keine probleme
schön schön hongkong und ein kleiner
stadtteil gefangen in der großen politik
mittendrin herr jan er wird alles
verlieren seine wohnung sein geschäft
sein zu hause bei uns herrscht das
gesetz des dschungels die schwächeren
werden von den stärkeren gefressen wie
gehören zu den gruppen die ausgeschieden
werden aber die menschlichkeit sollte
unsere regierung nicht vergessen
sie kann doch etwas machen geredet doch
immer von harmonie
ich hoffe der staat interessiert sich
nicht nur für die wirtschaftserfolge
sondern auch für die menschlichkeit
angelockt von der hoffnung auf ein
besseres leben ist er ja einst nach
tschechien gekommen nun frisst in chinas
großer traum vom reichtum auf